european union agriculture ministers  have agreed on the need to simplify the  way the e use fruit and vegetable sector  is run and to cut red tape for producers  during debate in luxembourg on the way  the sectors functioning since reforms  were introduced in 2007 the ministers  also underlined the need for greater  legal certainty for fruit and vegetable  growers all Member States had the  opportunity to give us their views on  this very important issue this  discussion will of course continue the  debate was based on a report from the  European Commission focused on the  implementation of provisions on producer  organisations operational funds and  programs and included a questionnaire  prepared by the Greek presidency the  2007 reform was aimed at strengthening  the sector and preventing crises in the  market the Commission is likely to use  this debate to prepare new legislative  proposals